[Música]
Rusia petó la resolución del Consejo de
Seguridad de la ONU que buscaba condenar
los referendos de anexión rusa en cuatro
regiones ucranianas esto luego que el
presidente Vladimir Putin oficializara
unilateralmente la incorporación de
donies lugans gerson y zaporiya a la
federación rusa movimiento rechazado por
los principales actores de la comunidad
internacional
la hora tormenta tropical Ian sigue
causando estragos a su paso por Estados
Unidos el estado de Carolina del Sur es
el último en sufrir su poder devastador
entre tanto en el estado de Florida el
panorama sigue siendo desolador por los
destrozos de Ian que azotó Florida como
huracán de categoría 4
el presidente de Nicaragua Daniel Ortega
aseguró que no quiere mantener
relaciones diplomáticas con los Países
Bajos si bien por el momento esto no sea
materializado en una ruptura de
relaciones por otra parte la
vicepresidenta Rosario Murillo aseguró
que Nicaragua no aceptará al nuevo
embajador propuesto por Washington
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 José Rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos en Rusia donde
el presidente Vladimir Putin firmó
finalmente el decreto para la anexión de
los territorios ocupados en Ucrania
durante un evento celebrado en el
kremlin Putin proclamó la integración de
lugans do Iniesta por yerson a la
federación rusa una zona que equivale a
un 15% del territorio ucraniano la
propia Ucrania Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea han denunciado los referendos
celebrados en esas regiones como
ilegales tiltándolos de farsa El
mandatario ruso volvió a atacar y
amenazar a occidente asegurando que
defenderá a los territorios por todos
los medios
hoy firmamos los tratados sobre la
admisión en Rusia de la repúblicas de
doniach y lugans de la región de
zaporiya y de la región de gerson
la elección de la población
no está en discusión Rusia no la
traicionará
y las autoridades de kiev deben tratar
esa libre voluntad del pueblo con
respeto y no de otra manera Ese es el
único camino hacia la paz
defenderemos nuestra tierra utilizando
todas las fuerzas y medios a nuestra
disposición y haremos todo lo posible
para proteger la seguridad de nuestro
pueblo esa es la gran misión libertadora
de nuestro pueblo posteriormente Nueva
York fue discutida en el consejo de
seguridad de Naciones Unidas una
resolución de condena a la anexión de
las zonas ocupadas que fue presentada
por Estados Unidos la resolución fue
vetada por Rusia miembro permanente del
organismo nuestra sale la gran manzana
nos amplía
Sí una vez más una resolución no sale
adelante por el veto de Rusia que como
saben es miembro permanente del Consejo
de Seguridad y tiene este derecho la
resolución ha contado con el apoyo de 10
países y uno en contra que es
precisamente la federación rusa y cuatro
ascensiones India gabón China y Brasil
se trata de una resolución presentada
por Estados Unidos y por Albania que
condenaba esos referéndums denunciados
internacionalmente que se han celebrado
en esas regiones ucranianas para
anexionar cuatro territorios a Rusia la
representante de Estados Unidos asegura
que se trata de una farsa que se ha
realizado a punta de cañón de pistolas
rusas y le pide a Rusia que revierta su
decisión y que saque inmediatamente las
tropas militares de suelo ucraniano por
su parte la federación rusa responde que
Estados Unidos y Albania presentando
esta resolución lo que están haciendo
puedes provocar una provocación de bajo
grado según la federación rusa estas
estas votaciones han contado con estos
referendos se ha contado con el apoyo de
los habitantes de estas cuatro regiones
ucranianas y además dice que cuentan
también con el apoyo de los
organizadores de Los observadores
Internacionales esta resolución pasará
ahora a la asamblea general de las
Naciones Unidas y allí no hay ya derecho
a veto cambiamos de tema porque Ian pasó
de fortalecerse nuevamente a huracán de
categoría 1 antes de golpear las costas
de Carolina del Sur a debilitarse para
ser catalogado como ciclón posttropical
a pesar de haber bajado su intensidad
las autoridades esperan que el fenómeno
meteorológico se aleje para comenzar a
evaluar los daños ocasionados mientras
esto sucede en Florida el panorama es
desolador Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
resucitado en las aguas del Atlántico y
antojó nuevamente tierra Este viernes lo
hizo como huracán de categoría 1 en
Carolina del Sur las rachas de viento
llegaron a alcanzar los 140 kilómetros
por hora sin embargo su contacto con
Tierra Firme lo debilitó y pasó a
convertirse en ciclón post Tropical
los vientos más fuertes ocurrirán esta
noche en el área de los tres condados
del norte de charleston a través de
gramstrong posiblemente vean ráfagas de
viento de entre 120 y 140 kilómetros por
hora y de 80 a 112 kilómetros por hora
tierra adentro Mientras tanto los ojos
de la Unión Americana continúan en la
devastación que el huracán de categoría
4 Causa en Florida
he ordenado que se tomen todas las
medidas posibles para salvar vidas y
ayudar a los sobrevivientes porque cada
minuto cuenta no solo una crisis para
Florida Esta es una crisis
estadounidense apenas estamos comenzando
a ver la escala de esa destrucción Es
probable que se clasifique entre
proveedores de la nación y entre en los
peores de la historia ustedes vieron las
escenas en la televisión casas y
propiedades arrasadas la reconstrucción
llevará meses años
aseguró que el Gobierno Federal cubrirá
Los costos de la limpieza de escombros
un paso clave para iniciar el proceso de
recuperación en medio de la destrucción
el gobernador ron de santis lanzó una
advertencia a quienes quieran
aprovecharse de la situación
es particularmente en aquellas áreas que
fueron muy afectadas es que queremos
asegurarnos de mantener la ley y el
orden ni siquiera piensen en saquear ni
siquiera piensen en tomar ventaja de las
personas en esta situación vulnerable la
policía local está involucrada en el
monitoreo de eso
hasta el momento se contabilizan más de
una veintena de muertes en la Península
al menos 1,8 millones de negocios y
casas particulares continuaban sin
electricidad este viernes
vamos ahora hasta Cuba La Isla aún
enfrenta las consecuencias que dejó el
paso de Ian y según una exclusiva del
Wall Street journal el gobierno cubano
habría emitido una rara solicitud de
asistencia de emergencia a los Estados
Unidos esto aún no ha sido confirmado
por las autoridades cubanas Y es que la
nación se ha visto fuertemente afectada
por los cortes eléctricos generalizados
que han durado varios días y que
llevaron a los ciudadanos a protestar
esto sumado a la ya difícil situación
por la escasez de medicinas combustible
y alimentos el gobierno cubano defiende
su gestión de la crisis y asegura que el
50% de la red ya se ha restablecido y
dice que las protestas Solo han
contribuido a ralentizar los esfuerzos
de recuperación yo creo que protestar es
un derecho
pero es un derecho cuando la responsable
el estado del gobierno está dejando de
hacer lo que le compete
pero yo creo que en las condiciones que
estamos hablando de la protesta de ayer
en vez de ayudar
frenan el cumplimiento de esa Misión y
de ese deseo que tenemos nosotros que en
el menor tiempo posible Tener la
recuperación total desde Nicaragua
llegan nuevas noticias de las tensas
relaciones que mantiene el país con
varios países de la órbita internacional
este viernes el presidente Daniel Ortega
aseguró que no quiere mantener
relaciones diplomáticas con los Países
Bajos Ortega calificó al país europeo de
intervencionista y recordó que el país
europeo suspendió en 2018 la
construcción de un hospital en una
ciudad del Caribe al norte de Nicaragua
Por el momento no sean materializado una
ruptura de relaciones por otra parte la
vicepresidenta Rosario Murillo aseguró
que Nicaragua no aceptará al nuevo
embajador propuesto por Washington se
trata de Hugo Rodríguez Aquí en
Nicaragua considera un inje está insigne
luego que el pasado 28 de Julio asegurar
ante el senado estadounidense que
apoyaría el uso de todas las
herramientas económicas y diplomáticas
para lograr un cambio de dirección en
Nicaragua
el señor Hugo Rodríguez y lo decimos
enfáticamente no será bajo ninguna
circunstancia admitido en Nicaragua y
mucho menos como exponente de las peores
formas
de una ofensiva e irreverente modalidad
de relaciones entre Estados que
contraviene desde sus mismos inicios la
convención de Viena hasta aquí este
informativo no olviden seguir nuestro
cubrimiento de estas y otras noticias
internacionales en nuestro portal France
24.com
[Música]